Oh, I've been dubbed many names by many people
A ruler, a Conqueror
For some of us, new worlds meant only one thing. New lands to be Conquered.
Into all out War. Each variant fighting to preserve their universe and annihilate the others.
Welcome back everyone is going to be my full
Loki Kang explainer video just explaining
every version of Kang it was tease during
the finale and what they're going to be doing
in the MCU going forward painfully Jonathan
majors he who remains version of Kang pretty
much explain the roadmap of what's happening
next.
They did a pretty good job of explaining his
backstory in the MCU.
And how he has sort of been around this whole
time but we haven't known about him till now.
Metaphorically and literally the man behind
the curtain.
So to speak to make a Wizard of Oz reference.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos this is
just the beginning obviously what they did
on Loki is going to affect all of the future
Marvel phase 4 movies in the Disney plus series
careful for spoilers if you have not see the
Loki episodes yet will be talking about everything
during the finale.
They call this version of Kang he who remains,
that's originally who Jonathan Majors was
cast to play interesting fact too, they actually
said that they contacted him about playing
he who remains first before he was cast in
Ant-Man 3 quantumania is Kang the conqueror.
So originally the he who remains character
was not supposed to be a Kang variant.
It wasn't till later when he went to audition
separately for Ant-Man 3 quantumania for the
Kang role that they liked him so much, they
just decided to combine the character of he
who remains with Kang the conqueror.
So this whole huge plot in marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5 argument however long Kang
remains in the MCU all started in a completely
different way they used to.
Like he was so fantastic the.
Like okay will now he has to be all the versions
of Kang and that is the idea.
Even though there will be some twist on that,
which will get to want to talk about the iron
lad version of Kang like there are other versions
of Kang that look different.
But this he who remains version is kind of
like the immortus version of Kang the final
version final boss form most powerful wisest
version he's one of the lesser evil versions
which he kind of explains during the episode.
Like this is if you think that I'm bad.
If you find the devil way to meet all my variance
you have no idea how battle get this is a
version of the character this live for millions
of years.
And that's kind of what he explains during
the episode.
I believe millions of lifetimes.
Just because the way he manipulated the sacred
timeline his own timeline to loop around on itself
So when he tells Loki and Sylvie, I've had
many names a been a conqueror.
I've been a ruler he's basically telling us
that he's technically been every single version
of the Kang character from the comics at different
points in his millions of years long lifetime
and I will explain all those different versions
because the way they presented them in the
comics, they were just alternate versions
of Kang, who just came back with different
identities like he would adopt a different
identity when he would come back in sometimes
they would be from alternate universes president
Rick Sanchez not the one this we Rick's travel
the infinite and switch places with each other.
Like hermit crabs I think.
But for talk about the classic versions from
the comics, he is closest to immortus in the
way that Jonathan majors he who remains explain
his back story.
He is the original variant the prime Nathaniel
Richards in the way that the version of Loki,
who died during avengers infinity war is meant
to be the prime Loki of the marvel cinematic
universe and all the other lokis that we meet
during the series are versions who were born differently
Like Sylvie or who did some really thing during
their lives to create nexus events like kid
Loki killed his version of Thor or in the
case of alligator Loki is kind of implied
that they did something really crazy and got
permanently turned into an animal.
But this version of Kang started life his
original life is Nathaniel Richards prime
born in the 31st century he's also a distant
descendent of Reed Richards father who was
also named Nathaniel Richards and was also
a time traveler he is loosely related to Eeed
Richards of the fantastic four.
But he was the first variant of the multiverse
to discover how the multiverse work how alternate
timelines work.
He calls it other universes stacked adjacent
to his own universe.
And even though it sounds kind of confusing
when you talk about the difference between
alternate realities, alternate dimensions,
alternate timelines, alternate universes way
the MCU categorizes them they're all kind
of the same thing for instance when these
branching timelines move past redline.
They start to function as fully alternate
universes, then when he says he first travel
to the nearest alternate universe he met an
alternate version of himself that looked exactly
the same they discuss the minor differences
in their universes and eventually more variance
of him started doing the same thing and they
were all cool with each other forming what
you will call the first Council of Kang's
there's 2 different versions of that the pop
up the second version is the same thing with
just a different group of kings so you have
different groups of them forming together
is not like all of them form a single Council
of Kang's but the way he explains it on the
Loki TV show that first Council which is a
bunch of Nathaniel Richards coming together
as scientists none of them had adopted any
the crazier comic book villain identities
yet.
They shared technology from each of their
universes and use that to help all their universes.
But as more and more variance started popping
up from newer and newer branch timelines newer
alternate universes.
Some of those alternate versions started going
around" conquering their own universes, then
trying to conquer the other universes in that's
where you get to the first multiversal Kang
war are Nathaniel Richards prime eventually
discovered Alioth, who was created from all
the dimensional tears in reality caused by
the multiverse war he says he went a little
dark.
Like experimenting on it, weaponized that
he gets kind of really angry and excited when
he talked about that I ended the multiversal
war.
Because Alioth is able to consume entire realities,
he uses Alioth to go around basically eat
all the other universes except for his own
he turns his timeline into the sacred timeline
then creates the TVA to prevent branch timelines
that would lead to dangerous versions of himself
dangerous variants from coming into existence
again.
The MCU.
As he of experiences so far and all the marvel
movies the infinity saga movies has taken
place inside the sacred timeline.
There is a multiverse that exists inside the
sacred timeline.
But it's only the subset of alternate universes
where dangerous versions of Kang don't rise up
That's how you have the doctor strange movie
where the ancient one is taking on the tour
talking about the multiverse.
So it existed before this, is that in all
those other universes other dimensions there
are evil versions of Kang otherwise he who
remains would've had the TVA clipped those
branches so to speak.
So after he does that then he just orchestrates
things managing the TVA for millions of years
in a cinched aged up into the immortus version
of Kang the final version who controls all of time
And during the episode.
The reason why he kind of wants Sylvie to
kill him why he's happy to be killed, although
he kind of doesn't care either way.
Is because he's tired like he wants someone
to either take over or get rid of him in the
comics, a version of him actually does that
with Renslayer sort of like the immortus version
of him hands over the reins of his entire
time empire chronopolis to Renslayer so when
we see this Kang statue the different one
of the TVA after Loki get sent back in implies
that when Sylvie kills he who remains Kang
the timeline restarted.
Like he said the multiversal war played out
again in the future, but a different Kang
wound up winning the war isolating his timeline,
then creating the TVA.
The showrunner the writers said it's meant
to feel like a very twilight zone kind of
ending like WTF wait a minute it as Loki comes
running up to this version of Mobius and Hunter
B 15 they explained whatever there in the
middle of right now, whatever crisis there
are 65 branches going past redline.
So it sounds like when this scene is happening
in the TVA they're still in the middle of
a huge fight with a bunch of alternate universe
versions of Kang, so I think the idea is that
they're just showing us that the multiverse
war plays out during many different points
in the timeline and working to see that play
out in future marvel movies and Disney plus series
And during Loki season 2.
So for instance the version of Kang the conqueror
the Jonathan Majors is going to play during
Ant-Man 3 quantumania will be a different
version all talk about that in a second to
because there are like the prime versions
of characters and then you have like a really
crazy alternate universe versions.
These are all the biggest versions that will
probably see either reference or actually
see them like physically on screen, played
by Jonathan majors.
But first, there's Rama tut, he's not the
first version of Kang, but he is the first
version that pops up in the comics his original
timeline a version of Kang takes Doctor doom's
time travel platform from the 20th century
sort of reworks it steals it uses it to conquer
his own home time of the 31st century then
travels back in time setting himself up as
the Pharaoh in ancient Egypt called Rama Tut
and makes his ship look like the great Sphinx
was a brief Easter egg for that when they
drove past the Sphinx in the great pyramid
of Egypt during episode five like this is
all obvious he foreshadowing the big Kang reveal
Then there was a scarlet centurion, that was
a version of Kang, who was inspired by Doctor
doom in present day to create a new special
armor suit he travel back to present day using
the special will sapping being to mind control
the avengers into believing that there was
no hope for the future, so just give up on
trying to help you just do what I say there's
the Mr. Griffin version of Kang in this is
actually where the big Kang industries Easter
egg for episode five comes from where it says
Kang industries on the stark tower the avengers tower
This is a version of him that got stuck in
the 21st century instead of waiting 2000 years
to get back to his own time.
The long way around.
He just decided to conquer present day using
the guise of a corporation creating Kang industries
then there was the victor timely version of
Kang it's a similar concept to the Mr. Griffin
version only it was a longer con he goes back
to the early 1900s creates a corporation called
timely industries that then grew very powerful
by present day of the avengers, there's the
iron lad version I know everyone's hoping
to see because we know were building up to
young avengers with all the big Disney plus
characters.
He started as a child version of Nathaniel
Richards who was being picked on by bullies
in older version of himself comes along to
save him saying look who you become you become
Kang the conqueror this very powerful warlord
in the future.
He tries to turn him evil ahead of schedule
before he becomes an adult.
But young Nathaniel Richards decides that
he wants to be good steals time travel gear
from the older version of himself was back
into the past and sets himself up as iron
lad trying to be a hero eventually he goes
off declaring that he's going to become the
best version of Kang a good version of Kang
in eventually went of turning into kid immortus.
So kid immortus is kind of like an iron lad
spin on the immortus character.
Then there's the Kang from the ultimate universe
ultimate Kang the conqueror.
This is actually the first female variant
of Kang like a Sylvie twist in this case is
actually a version of Sue storm from the fantastic
four.
That winds up becoming Kang in the future.
Then there's Kamala Kang, which is another
twist on the female Kang variant.
She's a version of Kang combined with Kamala
Khan ms marvel from her reality where Gamora
use the infinity stones to fold reality on
itself in a bunch of characters got combined
with each other.
Then there's the concept of Kang prime.
So he's actually meant to be the first comic
book version from where all the other versions
of Kang popped up to the way that they use
them in the MCU.
This he who remains version he's kind of like
the Kang prime.
But what they might do as they might just
say that Kang the conqueror in Ant-Man 3.
That version is the Kang prime the first evil
version who try to go around conquering the universe
He's also the version that created the Damocles
base the big sword shaped time ship he commands
this giant Army of scarabs and foot soldiers.
So it sounds like that's going to be the version
that we see during Ant-Man 3 quantumania them
not really expecting them to do this version
but it is this really crazy amalgam version
of Kang he's called doom the annihilating
conqueror and it's a version of doctor doom
from a fantastic story where they were using
his time travel platform to combine each other's
powers from different universes and Doctor
doom uses the process to give himself all
the powers of Kang the conqueror and a nihilist
at the same time.
Because obviously were heading into Ant-Man
3 quantumania doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
The reason why the quantum realm is so important
to this is because the way they used time
travel during avengers endgame.
They sort of canonize the quantum realm quantum
energy as the key to traveling to alternate
universes and traveling through time, so even
though they don't say it during the episode.
It's implied that this version of Nathaniel
Richards prime he who remains immortus is
using quantum energy to power all of his technology
the primate that little bit clear when we
get to Ant-Man 3 also just building more connections
between Kang in the other Ant-Man characters
don't be surprised if Janet van dyne knows
who Kang is when he shows up.
Because of his association with the quantum
realm traveling the multiverse time travel
back to Janet van dyne live for so long in
the quantum realm and knows all about the
quantum city and the other beings that lived
on their she would've probably encountered
him at some point also another big link a
lot of his technology is based on previous
technology that was iterated on by Iron Man
for instance like we talk about Doctor doom's
time travel platform that Kang uses in the
comics, they'll probably substitute iron man's
time travel platform for the MCU version of
that, even Kang's tempad wrist device looks
a little bit like the design language of iron
man's time travel wrist device.
But the ideas through marvel phase 4 Loki
season to all these big multiverse movies.
All the Marvel characters including Loki will
be trying to sort out the chaos in all the
changes to the timeline that these Kang's
from alternate universes are trying to perpetrate
the big explainer that miss minutes gave in
episode one about it, leading to the collapse
of all reality that was not a lie.
So that is the threat of this big giant multiverse
Kang war the collapse of everything will happen
though is when we see these alternate Kang
variance pop up in the different marvel movies
and different Disney plus series.
All do new explainer videos for those versions
to because the ideas that they'll have slightly
different back stories in their own timelines
their own universes.
But the be somewhat similar to our version
of Kang the we just saw as he who remains
in the next big marvel series is going to
be what if my episode videos for that will
start posting a couple weeks.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any those episodes.
I do like the idea that all these branching
timelines you see in the Loki finale is this
is all happening are creating the episodes
of marvel's what if like a lot of the variants
will pop up from these different universes.
Congratulations Bo Carranza your the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel video.
Please email me on the about page my channel
so I can get your contact details everyone
click here for my new Loki episode six, alternate
ending and deleted scenes video and click
here for my full Loki episode 6 finale video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!